this is my picture of the week two  children leaning against the bin on a  busy street in Istanbul outside I negr  me the new mosque I know that Street  exactly I've walked past there many  times myself these two Syrian children  are becoming emblematic of a problem  that is spreading across the country  there are 2.7 million Syrian refugees in  Turkey but only three hundred thousand  of them are taken care of in refugee  camps the rest have to fend for  themselves life should not be a hustle  for children and no child should have to  escape war and famine in their own  country only to face in a phobic attacks  elsewhere  while politicians in Brussels 2,000  miles away from Istanbul are trying to  iron out the details of a deal to bring  a solution to the refugee crisis the  reality remains the same